[Music]
and we begin tonight with a continuing
angle last night we were the first and
only primetime show to bring you the
outrageous story about a largely unknown
congressional slush fund one that as
Sean just references paid out about 15
point 2 million in taxpayer money to
victims of sexual harassment and
misconduct perpetrated by members of
Congress you'd be shocked to know that
some current members aren't even aware
that the fund exists do you support this
Schuss fund as it's being called no I
had in fact I had no idea that it
existed I'm like you know this seems
right you didn't know this one existed
congressman Jordan no I didn't I didn't
know that that was how it worked
you know just didn't did not know last
night we played for you some of the
explosive testimony of Representatives
Jackie Speier and Barbara Comstock
Democrat Republican they maintained
among other things that they know for a
fact that there are current members who
have engaged in sexually inappropriate
behavior so my question tonight is this
why aren't they naming names
why aren't others naming names and I'm
not the only one asking these questions
and demanding real answers I think it's
good to get this stuff out name them
just get it out let out and change the
rules so that people feel like they can
come to work without being harassed they
those who do these things need to be
held accountable you sure oh yeah he's
right of course and yes it is good that
Congress women are speaking out about
this and some congressmen but the
refusal to identify the members accused
of misconduct is I think in itself
enabling aren't they kind of in a sense
complicit in the cover-up and I know it
sounds harsh but don't they have an
obligation to reveal wrongdoing on the
part of their colleagues especially if
the misconduct is directed against young
vulnerable staffers does the leadership
have something to say about this by the
way we all have a right to know they
work for us and we the taxpayer
are footing the bill for this absurd
shush fun you know supposed to not talk
about it well we want to know the
details of these settlements we want the
time place and manner of the misconduct
and I want the names of the members
accused it is totally unacceptable for
Congress to operate under a different
set of rules and everybody else whether
it's the type of health care they vote
to give themselves or the amount of time
off they get or the way they get to use
OPM other people's money to pay off
settlements the American people I think
in both parties they want more
transparency and accountability in
government across the board and I'm
gonna promise you this I'm gonna stay on
this issue and others like it ours is
supposed to be government of the people
by the people and for the people not
government of anonymous gropers joining
us now with reaction is M Reese Everson
she's a former staffer for the
Congressional Black Caucus who accused a
congressman of sexual misconduct Reese
it is great to see you and your brave to
come in and we just really appreciate
your voice here I know you want this you
want to make this about the general
issue of sexual misconduct in Congress
because you were there you were fellow
at the Congressional Black Caucus just
briefly give us a rundown on what
happened to you you'd have to name the
name cuz I know for you it's traumatic
again but tell me what happened well as
I said I've worked for the CBC s and I
during that time experienced harassment
and at that time I didn't even know that
it was harassment I called it an
inappropriate experiment for those
comments
I experienced the conversation where a
person basically offered me an
opportunity to flirt with him in order
to excel in my career and that was the
gateway for the harassment me realizing
okay I've got to get out of here because
if I don't then I only have one option
and that's to comply and I don't want to
participate in that so I've got to just
leave when you say offered to flirt like
what would give me a little more on that
I'm not following that so Reese are you
gonna be a good girl mmm
uh what is that yeah what's that mean
well if you're gonna be a good girl
what's the point in you being there uh
hmm and I'm like a would and so he said
well are you gonna flirt with me and so
it was at that moment I realized okay
you've got to get out of here
because this is a situation that is only
going to turn for the worst and as a
young woman your instinct is fight
flight or freeze and my instinct was to
run and I tried to get away from the
situation by moving to another office
and that was not successful I was
retaliated against wrongfully terminated
and then blackballed and so my
experience was a very traumatic one
where not only because of speaking up
did I lose my job but my ability to find
another job and I think that that's the
worst part of all of this is the silence
it's it's a it's a pervasive incestuous
silence that keeps women hidden and
keeps women from speaking up because
they don't have the courage to speak out
against such a powerful person this was
in 2013 2013 how long by the time you
arrived for this fellowship which is
kind of cool to get I mean that's like
mean that's exciting when you get a job
it elects Congress you're a young woman
and you're going in there and you're
gonna learn about how Congress works and
so how long did the time you arrived at
Congress to the time this conversation
with this congressman I had been on the
hill for about seven months seven months
and had you heard from other people on
the hill other female staffers that this
had been a problem with other
congressmen any any word on this yes as
a matter of fact when you're applying
for the different offices or when
they're interviewing you to work in
different offices
you'll hear whispers or women will say
okay not that office because that one
has a history so there's a little system
a tweeting system if you will at
chirping maybe and warning other young
ladies to not to kind of stay away from
certain people but you hadn't heard
anything about this particular
congressman yeah and so you weren't able
to go to this accountability office
because you were a fellow and not a
full-time employee well the thing is
they let anyone send submit an
application for a complaint and
I did submit a formal complaint however
I'm ineligible because the CAA does not
cover interns or fellows now that in and
of itself is crazy I mean I'm not even
sure I don't really like a lot about
that accountability office because it
forces women or men complaining into
counseling mandatory mandatory
counseling the person who needs
counseling is the perpetrator but so I
don't I don't even know if I like a lot
of that but if there's going to be
protections in place why the heck aren't
they in place for interns and fellows
why should you only read it any
differently absolutely those are the
most vulnerable so this happens you
moved offices and when you were there
you were is it the same position another
fellow fellowship same position and the
office began to communicate and so
there's a conversation going on well why
did you leave did you know did you tell
people I try to explain oh well I'm just
looking for another you know some other
experience but when you say that the
person I said that to she said well well
why would you leave they wanted to hire
you full time are you an opportunist
will you just leave us - and I realized
I have to tell this woman the truth
because she's not going to give me the
credibility that I deserve so you did
another woman a woman rat you out of
this and then and then that it became
known that you were complaining about
the other in then she must have told so
the girl-power didn't really work in
your favor I didn't that instance
sometimes there's gatekeepers so women
who are enabling absolutely on Capitol
Hill are protecting their congressmen
absolutely these women have had these
jobs with these members for 15 and 20
years and they like the job security I
hope every I mean I hope everybody
across the country is just listen to
this young woman and this is outrageous
do you agree that the Congress women who
are in positions of great authority
should name names well now I'm talking
about the victim they're talking about
the members who did this I think there
should be a reporting system where the
Congress people it's like knowing if
you're an attorney and you see another
attorney drunk driving you have an
obligation to the bar to report this to
this attorney driving drunk the wrong
side
on the highway so as a member of
Congress I think you have an obligation
if you know that another member is
harassing young women or young men in
their office that you report it you
don't want to identify the congressman
not at all there's a fear of retaliation
even present day I really appreciate you
coming here Reese this I mean this has
got to stop
this has got to stop this is insanity
and this is government that we pay for
that's supposed to represent our
interests and there's people on a power
trip up there I don't know if they were
I said this last night I sound son
charitable I don't if they were like
geeks in school and they couldn't get
any girls and so now they get like a pin
on their lapel and they think oh I got
all the chicks at my disposal but that's
got to end as their show that said I
can't what is it house of cards
everything is about sex except for sex
sex is about power and so you have these
people with this power and they feel the
ability to wield it over anyone that
they see it's kind of like Simba in the
Lion King you are the king over
everything that you see in your kingdom
they feel that power over everything and
everyone and it's not fair for a young
beautiful woman to come in and for them
not to have power over her Reese thank
you for telling this shocking but I
guess for a lot of people listen it's
probably not all that shocking given the
low trust levels that Congress has right
now thank you so much thank you